we're officially eight hours into pride
month and here is what has happened so
far
the cartoon blues clues is teaming up
with a drag queen to indoctrinate kids
into lgbt ideology kellogg's cereal
wants kids to choose their own gender
pronouns and a first grade teacher
is instructing six-year-olds to pleasure
themselves
meanwhile the leading squish republicans
out there
are giving speeches about how we have to
ignore all of that
for them you see perverts in virtually
every powerful institution in the
country
preying on your kids it's just a culture
war distraction
from the far more forward-looking task
of cutting taxes like it's in 1986
on the bright side though there's some
good news out of blm there's a major new
expose on dr
fauci's role in the pandemic and a lot
more i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from black metal
matters it says they made conservatives
wear masks for a year
let's make them wear dunce caps for at
least that long oh it's going to be
longer my man i agree with the
sentiment but it's going to be much
longer than that because the masks are
still going on
and the dunce caps are unfortunately
harder to find but i agree we should be
doling them out absolutely you know
when you want to you know push back
against that
crazy leftist woke mob great way to do
it
listen to the jordan harbinger show make
sure to check out
jordan harbinger's new show the jordan
harbinger show
jordan's show which apple named as one
of its best in 2018
is aimed at making you better informed a
more critical thinker so that you can
get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening
even inside your own brain each episode
is a conversation
with a different fascinating guest when
i say there's something for everyone
here i really mean that in one episode
jordan talks to a hostage negotiator
from the fbi who offers techniques
on how to get people to like and trust
you which sounds
extremely useful slightly disturbing but
but very useful it's very how to win
friends and influence people
important stuff jordan recently had
oliver north on the libs did not like
that very much as you might imagine we
really enjoy this show
we think that you will as well there is
just so
much there you can head on over to
jordanharbinger.com
start and you can get some episode
recommendations there
or pretty simple you can just search the
jordan harbinger show
it's h a r b as in boy i n is in nancy g
e
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts
go check out the jordan harbinger show
today
hope you all had a terrific long weekend
that's what it was right that's
according to the vice president of the
united
states kamala harris it was just a long
weekend she got she got in a lot of
trouble
for tweeting this out she didn't say
grateful to all those who've served
think about
all the wonderful men and women who gave
their lives this solemn weekend of
memorial day no
she said enjoy the long weekend and
posted a picture of herself
and when she did that typically you know
as you might expect
everyone reacted on the right on the
left they didn't really react on the
right they did
and i thought you know this is a troll
they know what they're doing the
staffers who run that account
know exactly what they're doing to me it
was the
liberal version of the trump cinco de
mayo tweet do you remember this is one
of my favorite tweets trump ever sent
out
on cinco de mayo it's him eating a taco
bowl in his office and he said the best
taco bowls in the country
are at trump tower i love hispanics
and it was a perfect tweet because it
totally trolled the multiculturalists
and and it succeeded at doing that the
kamala tweet i think
was just the liberal version of that and
but instead of trolling
multiculturalists because we're not
multiculturalists
it was trolling patriots and so it's
terrible that's awful it's very
distasteful but i do think they know
what they're doing i don't think that
either tweet
trump's cinco de mayo tweet or kamala's
memorial day tweet i don't think either
of
those cost them one little bit of
support and it did enrage
their opponents that's the way it goes
but there are more serious ways the left
is trolling us right now
even you know disrespect to our troops
disrespect to our country that is par
for the course now on the left
but the radicalism is getting even
creepier and it's
really going after kids so just a quick
roundup now that we're what eight hours
eight and a half hours into pride month
and boy this is one for the
for the record books blues clues which
is a blues clues has been on the air
forever hasn't i mean i remember it even
when i was a kid it was on on the air
blue's clue's nickelodeon show is
teaming up
with a drag queen this pride month to
indoctrinate your kids
hey blue look at all these families
hi families it's time for a pride parade
family's marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
this family has two mummies they love
each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade okay so
you get the picture here uh this is a
cartoon drag queen
and singing about families this is going
to be the key i think to understanding
the radicalism here
is it's not hey look at these lesbians
look at these gay guys look at these
transgender people
look at these you know various eccentric
characters in the lgbt elementop
rainbow it's look at these families
because having succeeded at redefining
redefining marriage
now the radical sexual revolutionary
left is going to
try to redefine the family they're
already doing that but
it doesn't redefine the family when you
the
family has a natural component as well
as a social component
the natural part of course is men and
women are different they come together
the birds and the bees you know
they call up the stork store and they
get a little baby out of it
and then this propagates onward and you
can extend out where there are extended
families but it comes back to that mommy
and daddy
who get together one night and produce
cute little baby
when you redefine the family to take
away that natural component
you don't you don't create a new family
you just destroy the family
there are all sorts of social i have a
million social relationships but they
are not
the same as the family much like when
you redefine marriage and you
completely take out the the sexual
difference component which has been
intrinsic to marriage since the dawn of
time you don't
you don't just get new kinds of
marriages you actually destroy the
institution of marriage
they're not just using cartoon drag
queens here to push this
they're actually using little kids
themselves to push this ideology so on
blues clothes on the same show they get
this little girl i don't know she can't
be more than
six or seven years old to read out an
explanation
of what this new sexual revolution looks
like
it's an email from our
[Applause]
primal friends that everyone should be
equal no matter who they love
we celebrate primark because people in
the lgbtq plus community
who used to be treated unfairly now they
can beat themselves
openly and proudly look i made a prime
decoration
these flags represent different parts of
the lgbtq plus community
this rainbow flag is called the gay
pride flag
wow this one is called the non-binary
that's why it's called the lesbian flag
and
this one is called the trans-enterprise
flag
there's so many more flags those are
different communities
bye just bye bro so this is really
insidious because it's not just
indoctrinating kids in this new idea and
it's not it's not just a new sexual idea
we'll get to this in a second
it's much bigger than that but it's not
even just indoctrinating the kids
it's actually using the kids exploiting
the kids as mouthpieces
for this very radical sexual ideology
not just blues clues doing it kellogg's
cereal kellogg's has a new serial
box that is encouraging kids to choose
their own pronouns
so this it's not you've got it in the
mainstream media you've obviously got it
in
in the corporate america you know all
the corporations are gonna
have rainbows for the next month and
then you've got it
most especially in the schools so right
now dalton school which is a very posh
private school 55 000 a year to attend
the dalton school has been caught
teaching little kids to pleasure
themselves so it's not it's not even
just the
the broader ideology of lgbt and the
sexual revolution
it's actually instructing them that it
is
good to pleasure themselves so that the
director
of health and wellness justine aang
fonte at the at the dalton school is
now being reported by the new york post
uh instructing
six-year-olds during her sex ed class
to to touch themselves because it feels
good there's a slight viewer
fewer discretion pushed here
you know i would say maybe uh if if
you've got kids watching right now maybe
lower the volume for about
60 seconds or you know skip one two on
there because this is
really really creepy stuff i almost
didn't play it except i think it's
important
to hear what is being taught in first
grade classrooms now
all in the name of the sexual revolution
hey how come my penis gets big sometimes
and points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels good
sometimes when i'm in my bath or when
mom puts me to bed
i like to touch my vulva too you have a
clitoris there kayla that probably
feels good to touch the same way keith's
penis feels good when he touches it but
have you ever noticed that
older kids and grown-ups don't touch
their private parts in public
hmm they don't that's right keith
it's okay to touch yourself and see how
different body parts feel
but it's best to only do it in private
well
if private parts are so special why do
you cover them up
because they are private silly
that's right kayla because they are
private
this i think is the single creepiest
thing i've ever seen
i i don't think that's an exaggeration
you've got
these little cartoon kitty voices
talking about
sex and as woody allen says sex with
someone you love right sex
in the privacy of your own room and then
this teacher saying
well it's good it's okay it's totally
fine to do that in private but you don't
always want to do that
in public now this is part of the sex
ed class at dalton the reason i even
play it is not just how shocking and
creepy it is
but it's to show what this is really
about because the education that's being
conveyed in this video
is not just sexual education there's a
little bit of sexual education here's
this body part here's this body part
but it goes much further than that it's
morality education
it's religious education because what
this woman is saying is
look given the laws of our society it's
not okay
to do these sorts of things in public
but it's perfectly okay to do these
sorts of things in private
that's a moral teaching that's a
religious teaching that's not the
christian understanding of it the
christian teaching is it's not okay to
do that in private
jewish understanding as far as i know
i'm no expert not okay to do muslim
understanding it's not okay to do that
in private
but the leftist understanding is it is
okay it's actually good
you should be doing it this goes back
way way far back this goes back almost
100 years
to theorists like wilhelm reich very
creepy
sexual and political theorist who said
that all the problems of the world from
war to disease or caused by a lack of
orgasms
seriously he had he had an orgone
accumulator is what he called it
it was a like an orgasm box where
many very intelligent leftists bought
these boxes and sat in them i don't know
what they did
i don't i don't want to know what they
did in those boxes but but these
theories were
very popular bernie sanders adopted them
in the 1960s he wrote creepy essays
about it that he published in the
vermont freeman i think the name is i
actually talked about this at some
length in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now pre-order you get assigned
first edition of premiere collectibles
there was a very creepy focus on the
need to sexualize kids
and the reason is if you really believe
that sexual repression
is the cause of all these problems in
the world then you can't wait until
people
embrace the oppression you can't can't
wait until people decide they are going
to repress themselves
you've got to get them at their very
youngest point and so you've got to go
into the schools and you've got to
indoctrinate kids
in this radical sexual ideology it's
creepy it's pervy but for the left it
serves
a political purpose when we want to
protect ourselves from all sorts of
things
highly recommend checking out ring it's
very important to be able to keep
an eye on your house what's going on
inside and especially what's going on
outside especially for me right now
because i have my cute little
four-month-old baby all right so i want
to make sure
that he's hanging out with the right
crowd you know when his little baby
friends roll up in the hot wheels i want
to be able to look and say okay are you
gonna
is this the right kind of baby crowd
that you wanna be hanging out with if
you wanna know who's at your door i
strongly recommend you check out ring to
get ring alarm for yourself
just it's very simple head on over to
ring.com
knowles it's a great way to start your
ring experience i really love these guys
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door whether you're in your home or
whether you're at the office or whether
you're on vacation on the other side
of the world it's a terrific way to do
it you can do it right from your
phone if it's you know the pizza
delivery guy you go open to the door if
it's your mother-in-law maybe you you
know you just
you use your judgment you use your own
prudence okay it's great makes a great
gift as well
uh because it's super terrific
technology and
not very expensive so you get credit for
a great gift
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get your ring alarm security
kit you can build the system that's
right for you have it up and running in
minutes that's ring.com
knowles ring.com knowles ring a great
way
to protect yourself today
so you got the left focusing on this
really
really creepy sex stuff
and to give them their credit it's not
just because they're perverts
it does have a political purpose
ginning up lust ginning up
licentiousness
lectures all this sort of stuff is
designed to control you politically
and i know that sounds kind of
conspiratorial but it's actually a very
basic principle
free people cultivate their higher will
and their intellect so they can control
all of their base appetites
unfree people slavish people just
pursue their basest desires whether
that's for drugs whether that's for sex
whether that's for any any sort of base
desire
the example i often use is the heroin
addict the heroin addict who just shoots
up heroin all the time
according to the modern leftist view
seems very free because he can do
whatever he wants and he can go shoot up
and that's nobody's going to stop him
but we all know he's a slave and this is
true of all of our
passions and our lusts especially sexual
ones because
it's a very big driver of human behavior
especially for dudes so the left does
have a vested interest
in breaking down all all these sorts of
um moral codes and the founding fathers
wrote about this right they said you
you should not abuse your liberty to
licentiousness
he's very very focused on that sort of
thing and the whole point of pride month
it's not even just a
it's not about gay people really anymore
right i mean i guess that's part of it
but it's about
all this sort of sexual stuff which it
actually
tends to have a much broader point now
this is religious
education that people are being taught
it's it's a part of the liturgical
calendar i mean
you've got the religious you know the
christian liturgical calendar you've got
months to the sacred heart of jesus
or the months to the holy family or what
and in the leftist calendar you've got
months to
pride you've got months to women's
history you've got monster black history
right all these sorts of things
we are following these religious
pathways we're following these religious
longings because man is fundamentally a
religious being and all human conflict
is theological
but some republicans don't get that i'm
thinking right now of paul ryan paul
ryan
who was the former speaker of the house
where he was a leader of the sort of
dignified republican party i know a lot
of people hate
i say dignified in quotes you know so
i'm the republican with dignity i'm the
sort of you know
the sophisticated republican not that
kind of conservative a lot of people
have
great antipathy toward paul ryan i don't
you know i thought he was good on
entitlement reform he's but
he doesn't know what time it is he's
kind of missing the point he gave a big
speech
at the reagan library last week in which
he laid out his vision for the
republican party
and i want to like paul ryan i want to
support paul ryan he seems like a nice
guy
but he just totally
missed the point you've got kid
you've got kids being steeped in this
insane
leftist pervy sexual ideology
and all paul ryan wants to talk about is
going back to the 1980s basically so he
opens up and he says look
the party that's following trump we've
got to
stop that if we if we just have this
obsession with this one guy we're not
going to move forward as a party
2020 left republicans powerless in
washington
even worse it was horrifying to see a
presidency come to such a dishonorable
and disgraceful end
so once again we conservatives find
ourselves at a crossroads
and here's the reality that we have to
face
if the conservative cause depends on the
populist appeal of one personality
or of second-rate imitations then we're
not going anywhere
voters looking for republican leaders
want to see independence in metal
they will not be impressed by the sight
of yes men and flatterers flocking to
mar-a-lago
we win majorities by directing our
loyalty and respect to
voters and be staying faithful to the
conservative principles that unite us
okay so no cult of personality we can't
just be focused on one guy or second
rate imitators
we've got to talk about something beyond
just one guess so what are we going to
talk about paul ryan
even 40 years after president reagan's
first inauguration
we all remember him with a special
respect and affection
he was exactly the man america needed at
a crucial moment
we appreciate him only more from a
distance of time now
to this day whenever i'm asked to
describe my own political outlook
there's no term that fits more
comfortably than
reagan conservative just think
how different the world would look today
without this one man whose arrival in
american politics still
seems providential
you know it's a measure of his impact
that there are statutes of this man
not just here in simi valley but also in
our capital rotunda
in london in gdansk poland
in warsaw in budapest in berlin near
where the wall used to be and in many
other places
where reagan will always be an honored
name
we've got to stop being a cult of
personality you know we've got
all these stupid trump people they just
all they care about is this one man we
got to stop that
and talk about reagan reagan reagan
reagan reagan
reagan reagan reagan reagan reagan
reagan we've got to stop
following the cheap imitators of that
one
cult of personality you know which is
why i'm a reagan conservative all my
views are from ronald reagan we need to
go
do you hear yourself do you hear look i
love ronald reagan i like donald trump a
lot too
i like these guys but you can't attack
the trump people
for the cult of personality when every
other word out of your mouth
is ronald reagan now eventually paul
ryan comes to a point he comes to the
issues that we've got to talk about what
is it we've got six-year-olds
being told to do all sorts of creepy sex
stuff to themselves
we've got other six-year-olds on kids
television shows
teaming up with drag queens talking
about the transgender flag
so what is it what's what's going to be
the big
focus here paul ryan oh the biggest
issue is let me check my notes
taxes and then there was the first major
revision of the tax code since 1986.
the previous code was what people had in
mind when they talked about the swamp
it's right there that is not what people
had in mind when they talk about the
swamp
when people talk about the swamp they
talk about the gigantic national
security state
and intelligence gathering state that
undermined a duly elected president for
four years
at least for four years that's what
we're talking about with the swamp
we're not just talking about freaking
taxes paul ryan he goes through he says
what did we do when we were
when i was a speaker and we did this and
he's talking about all these little
we beefed up the defense budget we did
this you know this that and the other
thing
but the most important thing we did the
greatest most
conservative thing in the whole wide
world
is cutting taxes a little bit
it was a constant drag on economic
productivity and entrepreneurship
driving capital and jobs outside of the
united states
it was such a fixture that few people
thought it could be reformed and most
had given up
trying we needed to lower the rates
clear away the favors and the clutter
and sharpen america's competitive edge
tax reform was a big piece of business i
worked at it myself for two decades in
congress
and in 2017 we got it done
this is the main reason why at the start
of 2020
the united states was seeing such
powerful and inclusive economic growth
we saw increased revenue from a broader
tax base
capital and jobs coming back to america
the best
wage growth for low-income earners in
more than a decade
an unemployment at a 50-year low for
every demographic
these historic reforms were a triumph of
practical conservative policy
a model of shared prosperity and upper
mobility that we've always talked about
it was the populism of president trump
in action
tethered to conservative principles and
we
conservatives have got to be careful not
to get caught up in every little
cultural battle
sometimes these skirmishes are just
creations of outraged peddlers detached
from reality and not worth anybody's
time
did he finally stop talking about taxes
is he i don't know i
i sort of lost track there for a moment
we need to stop hold on i think
in my dream fugue state i i think i
heard that
we need to focus on cutting taxes a
little bit again that will save the
country you know we cut taxes in 86
the only policy we've all agreed on
since then is cutting taxes
during that time the definition of
marriage has fallen apart
we've now got transgenderism in the
schools blm is on the rise burning down
the country
antifa is threatening any conservative
speaker you're barely allowed to wave
the american flag in your workplace
anymore but hey at least we cut taxes
the most
conservative policy imaginable and you
know there are look there are these
cultural distractions culture war
distractions
but we we shouldn't focus on that guys
we got to focus on what really matters
which is saving a little bit more money
which by the way doesn't even end up
saving you money
and it doesn't even look i love tax cuts
as much as the next guy doesn't end up
saving you money
because if all you focus on is keeping a
little bit more money and you let the
entire culture go away
then the culture is going to come back
and take your money which is what's
happening right now
so it's happening right now there were
no lasting gains i can't believe
this guy gave this speech at this moment
it's like he is
living on another planet he's just it
they're following this happened in in 92
there's a big debate in the republican
party do you go to george h.w bush route
we've just won the cold war do you only
pursue
slightly better trade deals or and end
up actually raising taxes if you're
george h.w bush or do you go to the pap
buchanan route and actually focus on the
cultural stuff the gop chose the bush
route
look where we are today speaking of
financial matters you gotta check out
truebill
truebill is the smartest way to manage
your finances it's an easy to use app
you can review your recurring charges in
one place
and cancel subscriptions directly
through the app truebill
has a variety of tools to help customers
improve their finances
you create a monthly budget you track
and evaluate savings goals
and get push notifications when you're
getting close to going over your budget
or when your cash is running low work
with many of the nation's top
providers to negotiate and lower your
bills
people think that they spend around 80
bucks a month on subscriptions do you
know what the actual number is
it's closer to 200 a month okay truebill
has saved its users
more than 50 million dollars that's a
lot of money
and by the way if you're if your bills
are 50 million dollars a month you've
got other problems as well go check out
true bill the average person saves
720 per year with true bill could you
use an extra 720
i certainly could get started today with
truebill.com knowles
take control of your finances start
saving it truebill.com
knowles that is truebill.com
knowles go check out truebill today
there's ben's gonna be talking about a
lot of great stuff today he's gonna be
talking about when the demand for racism
outstrips supply uh he's gonna be
talking about the actress ellie kemper
i don't even a lot of these woke actors
and actresses i don't even know about
them so go check that out you can also
check out ben's new book the
authoritarian moment which is available
now for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble and any other major
bookseller
someday when i run for office that will
be my campaign tagline
knowles 2024 the authoritarian moment so
go
go get a preview at ben's book today
we'll be right back with a lot more
paul ryan is not the only republican
politician who doesn't know what time it
is there's another guy who
he's he's a movie star but he seems to
want to become a politician
who also just has no idea what time it
is that would be
matthew mcconaughey all right all right
all right
matthew mcconaughey appeared on the
carlos watson show
and his his big move to get into texas
republican politics
was to defend the masks now we talked on
the show on friday
about a new study that's out that shows
that the masks
are completely ineffective the only
effect they have is political no
particular medical or scientific benefit
i know that the the censors and the fact
checkers are going to hate that go back
and watch the show i read the
the study at times verbatim matthew
mcconaughey goes on the show
he goes i'm not believing you know i
can't really do mcconaughey
i'm not believing you're really scared
of this little cotton thing
i'm not believing you really feel that
takes away your identity
and your freedom this the mask is a
short-term inconvenience for long-term
freedom
there's no data that says it's not a
good thing no data that says it's
harmful so
again that isn't true you can go back
and watch the shows let's all take one
for the team here mcconaughey just like
totally totally wrong perfectly wrong
here
uh it's not that i'm scared of the
little cotton thing i mean they're
filthy they're disgusting masks so i
don't like that i find that repulsive
but i'm not i'm not afraid of the mask
i'm afraid of what it does to our
politics
i'm not really believing you think this
takes away your identity and your
freedom it
certainly takes away my freedom i'm not
allowed i've just muzzled myself
everywhere now
it takes away many of my political
rights but also
it does take away my identity covers up
my face aristotle says man is the
political animal
because we can speak so when you muzzle
yourself up you are depriving yourself
of quite a bit of your freedom and your
identity it's a short-term inconvenience
for long-term freedom it was supposed to
be 15 days you remember that
and from the beginning there were the
pro-mask people even pro-mass
conservatives who said look
if we just wear the mask for a little we
can get back to normal life and i said
that's not true that's bs
they're going to use the masks as a
symbol of how we can't get back to
normal life because
people don't ordinarily wear masks when
you see a mask it doesn't assuage your
anxiety it actually makes you feel more
anxious because you think oh my gosh
we're really in the heat of something
bad here folks
if we had just taken the masks off from
the beginning well i guess i did but
a number of people did not if we as a
culture had taken the masks off from the
beginning we would be
in a far far better political situation
so mcconaughey is thinking that he might
run for governor of texas or something
he should not he should not run he
should not be elected
this reminds us that it is good to elect
people who know things i know that
politics has always been a sort of
popularity contest
increasingly it's become a reality tv
show
it is good to elect people who know
things
you know donald trump is like edmund
burke compared to matthew mcconaughey
this guy doesn't know
anything if this is the kind of
statement he's making he doesn't know
anything about politics and that's fine
maybe he can learn maybe he can wise up
but in the meantime it kind of kind of
gets me on the caitlyn jenner point in
california
why would we elect a very liberal person
who maybe would cut taxes or something
if they're going to throw away the whole
culture if they're going to say yeah we
should all muzzle up
ad infinitum or yes we should embrace
radical gender ideology
why would we do that to save a little
money on taxes it won't last
even that won't last it wouldn't be a
good deal even if it did
but if you're going to lose the whole
culture it just ain't worth it folks
yes we'll save 30 pieces of silver on
your taxes
but you'll lose the whole thing now some
politicians do have their priorities in
order i'm
speaking of course about my friend ted
cruz
ted cruz uh along with mike braun and
cynthia
lummus three republican senators
just introduced a bill on friday to ban
the federal government from establishing
coronavirus passports
i love this i'm so glad that senator
cruz is doing this
so much of the covid fight is at the
state level because that's where a lot
of the
mandates are going to be enforced and
where they're really going to affect
people
but you can do some stuff at the federal
level and
senator cruz is leading the way here
which is
ban the coronavirus passports that is
insane it's a huge invasion
of privacy it is a huge handing over of
our medical data
to people that i don't think deserve it
it's all for a virus that poses
relatively little threat to
most people right to young people
have basically zero risk at all and
people who are in at-risk groups
very unhealthy or overweight people or
very old people
can take precautions but there is no
reason to require this insane
passport to show that you've had the
hastily developed vaccine
where we're hearing more and more
stories every day about issues with that
vaccine
or with those vaccines rather cruz great
doing a great job as our
senators braun and llamas also dan
crenshaw and tom cotton
doing great stuff it's so rare that
anything good happens out of the capital
that i feel we should highlight it
when it does dan and uh and senator
cotton came out
and they're both military veterans and
they are teaming up to create a
whistleblower form for military members
if they spot woke training efforts so
you remember this you saw the army ad
that came out last month where you know
the the
woman soldier says you know the reason
that i'm such a great soldier
is because i was raised by two lesbians
and i went to a lot of pride parades and
that's what's going to really help me
kill my enemies
and then we compared that to the russian
army ad which is a god of a job but in
some guy with a neck you know the size
of a school bus was just like shooting
guns at his enemies
and you think well one of these is more
intimidating than the other one um
we were told you can never criticize the
sort of woke infiltration of the
military
well dan and and senator cotton are
doing that
so great stuff i'm really glad they're
doing it we do need to push back
there is no definition of freedom or
tolerance that should permit us to
tolerate this kind of insanity and
you're going to see a lot more of it
this is day one we're now officially
nine hours into day one of pride month
it's gonna get crazier speaking of our
officials overseas
some more great stuff coming out of the
house led by
the new gop conference chair elise
stefanik
who you know i've said i'm a little
skeptical of her she's got a bit of a
liberal voting record
but this is great stuff got to give her
credit got to give some encouragement
ali stefanik uh nicole malliotakis
i'm probably going to mispronounce a lot
of these names ken buck michael guest
daryl issa
brian mast and pete sessions i just
introduced the stars and stripes act of
2021
very simple after the secretary of state
under biden
said that embassies abroad can fly the
blm flag can you imagine that
and embassies abroad are flying other
flags including the gay pride flag
this bill comes out and says that
no the the only flags that you're
allowed to fly at these embassies are
the u.s flag good the flag of the
country where the
where the embassy is located makes sense
the flag of a state
territory or possession of the united
states fair enough
a departmental or secretarial flag so
you know the state department flag or
whatever one of these
or the prisoner of war missing an action
flag
which you know in past what five or six
decades has been popularized
for our servicemen who were left abroad
those are the only ones those are the
five flags that you can fly i love it
absolutely right a blm flag has no place
on
an embassy the pride flag has no place
on an embassy
there is there is some political
significance here in that
the blm flag and the pride flag are sort
of symbols
of american imperial hegemony right
there there are flags that are
associated with the imperial ambitions
of america
because they're transnational ambitions
that seek to gin up
uh tensions and political movements
overseas as well because they make
universal claims blm about the
oppression of black people
and pride about sexual oppression so
this goes
well beyond national boundaries but we
should we should not be flying either of
those flags no way about it now speaking
of blm
some actually some good news coming out
of blm you ever thought i'd say that
the uh founder of the black lives matter
chapter in saint paul
minnesota so this is the black lives
matter chapter in a place
that is very very involved
in the riots of 2020 right twin cities
were kind of leading the charge after
the death of george floyd
this guy richard turner i just posted a
video
last week in which he said he quit blm
after he
learned the ugly truth as an insider of
that group take a listen
that's why in 2015 i was the founder of
black lives matter in saint paul
i believe the organization stood for
exactly what the name implies
black lives do matter however
after a year on the inside i learned
they had little concern for rebuilding
black families
and they cared even less about improving
the quality of education for students in
minneapolis
that was made clear when they publicly
denounced charter schools
alongside the teachers union i was an
insider in black lives matter
and i learned the ugly truth the
moratorium on charter schools does not
support rebuilding the black family
but it does create barriers to a better
education for black children
i resigned from black lives matter after
a year and a half
but i didn't quit working to improve
black lives and
access to a great education today
i serve as the president and executive
director of minnesota parent union
we are dedicated to helping parents move
their children from failing schools
to successful schools it's hard work
and we're up against forces that don't
want us to succeed
but success is possible just look at me
and the hundreds of children and
families we've helped to pursue a great
education
break the chains of poverty and lead a
life of success
great stuff i'm you know glad to see
that he's
hopped out of blm and he's doing
something productive this is great stuff
he said here that he was shocked because
he
thought that blm was going to be about
rebuilding the black
family but then it turns out they
actually don't they're just kind of in
cahoots with these crooked political
organizations like the teacher unions
who are opposing charter schools which
are one of the few
opportunities for poor
disproportionately black people
to break out of bad schools and get a
good education
he should have read the blm website
before he joined up
because the blm website was very clear
about this they said they don't want to
rebuild the family they want to disrupt
the family do you remember they've since
taken the page down but it was up for
years
the page said and i'm only slightly
paraphrasing
black lives matter seeks to disrupt the
western prescribed nuclear family
structure
and that's what this is all about goes
right back to that drag queen at the top
of the show on blue's clues it says look
at all these families look at all these
families they're not
they're they're not recognizing
different types of families they're
trying to
destroy the family structure itself the
same radicals who are pushing blm and
the radical pride ideology and all of
these things
see the family as an impediment to
liberation and it actually makes sense
the family is the basic political
institution and
the progressive project is about
destroying all of those intermediating
political institutions
that prevent them from taking full power
because you you
are inhibited from total liberation
by your family right if you define
liberation as just doing whatever you
want at any given time
if you define it as licentiousness then
the family does stop you from doing that
because daddy will come in and say no
don't do that son
the local local government does that too
the local institutions the church does
that too
which is why the left in the name of
liberation
seeks to destroy all of those
institutions but most especially the
family
because that's the hardest nut to crack
that's the natural political institution
that they can't quite get over so
they're going to put all their guns
behind it they're going to put all of
their resources and efforts
behind that sort of thing and they'll do
it through blm should blm are good
useful idiots for that or or
through the radical pride ideology but
that is what
they are after and the the radicals are
not just in blm okay it's not just
rashard turner's former colleagues
they're all the way up
at the top of the federal government joe
biden who's whose great political
utility right now
is that he doesn't seem like a radical
because he's held relatively
conservative positions in the past
and he's an extremely old guy who talks
very quietly and mumbles his words and
he just he doesn't seem
totally extreme but joe biden is nothing
right
that the trick of joe biden is that he
doesn't believe anything he just wakes
up he licks his index finger
figures out which way the wind is
blowing he goes there so now old sleepy
joe
has changed his opinion on a lot of
important political issues
to follow the radical left because he
thought it would help him politically
and one of those issues
is the hyde amendment so right now what
is the height amendment the height
amendment
prohibits taxpayer dollars from going to
abortion and it's kind of fake
because we still give taxpayer dollars
to planned parenthood we just say you
can't spend this money on abortion but
money is fungible it's not like you take
a dollar and you say okay this dollar is
going to go here but this dollar can't
go here you just
throw in a bank account they spend it
however however they're going to spend
it
still hypocrisy is the tribute advice
pays to virtue we've had this
very firm line here for years and years
joe biden was a big defender of that
line
well now he's getting rid of it in the
2022 budget
that he is proposing that will include
taxpayer funding
for abortion and the argument he gives
is actually somewhat sound
it's ghastly it's evil but it's somewhat
sound here's what he writes quote
i laid out a health care plan that's
going to provide federally funded health
care for all women and women who are now
denied even medicare
in their home states it became really
clear to me that although the hyde
amendment was designed to try to split
the difference here
you might say split the baby to make
sure women still had access
you can't have access if everybody's
covered by a federal policy
that's why at the same time i announced
the policy i announced
that i could no longer continue to abide
by the hyde amendment that's the reason
his argument is coherent which is
something that is not often said about
joe biden
what he's saying is yeah look when we
used to have a lot of different choices
when we used to have a lot of different
places that were offering health
insurance we used to have a lot of
intermediating institutions
we used to have all the way down to
families taking care of you but
certainly at the local community the
church
your employer health insurance when we
had all that
we could have the hyde amendment because
you just go to somewhere else
that that is offering you abortion
access
but now that we've destroyed all those
institutions
now that you're forced or strongly
strongly uh incentivized to go to the
federal government
we can't it's got it's a
one-size-fits-all policy so we've got
to pay for the abortions now i think
this was the plan all along but that
that we are seeing this play out in real
time right now
and it's not just the drag queens on
blues clues that are pushing the
radicalism it goes
all the way up to the top the drag
queens on blue's clues are a symptom
of the broader establishment problem of
how far left
it's going speaking of radicals in
public office not just joe biden
we've got the most radical guy in public
office most powerful politician in the
country you know who that is
dr fauci dr anthony fauci
director of the u.s national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases
since i think the year 1732
um dr fauci is in big trouble now
there was a big new report out about his
role in the origins of the coronavirus
and i know
that that report did not come out of the
united states because the mainstream
media here are totally in lockstep
with with the left and with dr fauci so
you have to go all the way to australia
you get this report in the australian
right now it's hard to find
uh headline anthony fauci backed virus
experiments
despite pandemic risks so two big issues
here with fouchy
one fauci did not warn
trump administration officials when the
ban on gain of function research
ended in 2017 so there had been a ban
up until the very first days of the
trump administration
on the kind of research gain of function
which just beefs up natural diseases
and makes them more transmissible more
infectious the sort of stuff that we're
seeing right now with the coronavirus
when that ban ended the guy who's
supposed to serve the president
did not tell them that because he
thought that it would be a good thing
fauci had previously argued that
that there are risks to gain a function
research you could unleash
a worldwide pandemic you acknowledge
this
it's all here in this report in the
australian but he said the benefits
outweigh the potential risks and dr
fauci was you'll be shocked to hear this
wrong he was dead wrong yet again
yeah and it's not even that he lied this
he has lied in the past but it's not
just that he lied this time it's just
that he was wrong
okay dr fauci wrong again
trump and all the people who called this
stuff a year ago
you know i hate to say i told you so
we're right again and the mainstream
media are having a really tough time
admitting this
so a year ago going back to this gain of
function research going back to the
wuhan laboratory
a lot of people said that it is not
guaranteed but
very plausible that the virus came from
the wuhan institute of virology which
had been conducting this kind of
research we were called conspiracy
theorists and idiots and rubes and
dummies and unscientific
and it turns out now we were right not
that it definitely 100
came from the lab but that it looks
increasingly likely
that it did john carl on abc news had to
admit
that just because donald trump says
something
does not mean that it is necessarily
incorrect
and yes i think a lot of people have egg
on their face this was an idea
uh that was first put forward by mike
pompeo
secretary of state donald trump and look
some things
may be true even if donald trump said
them
and there was because trump was saying
so much else
that was just out of control and because
he was uh you know making a
a a frankly racist appeal talking about
kung flu
and and the china virus his notion that
put forward that this may have or he
said flatly that this this came from
that lab
was widely dismissed but actually
there's some real reason we don't know
by the way we still don't know we
absolutely don't know
but now serious people are saying it
needs a serious inquiry
oh now the serious people are saying
that
this you see unserious people racist
evil terrible raised why is it because
because we said the virus came from
china that's racist you're not allowed
to say that
you can say the uk variant but you can't
say the china virus okay okay john corl
but he says look all these unserious
people
a year ago were right
and all the serious people were wrong
but now that the serious people are
saying that we were
we were right now we have to take it
seriously
you think maybe john carl is confusing
who the serious people here
are because i i'm
sort of not convinced that
the dr faucis of the world and the
mainstream media of the world and the
guys who got every single step of this
wrong i'm not convinced they're the
serious ones
i think maybe we're the serious ones i
think maybe it's exactly the opposite
of what we have been told
uh all of this going back to china by
the way you
remember last week john cena the fast
and furious guy made this groveling
apology in mandarin for saying that
taiwan as a country he was apologizing
to china
well didn't get him very far according
to the hollywood reporter
fast and furious 9 is bombing at the
chinese box office
uh the the receipts from it dropped 85
percent in the second weekend
the lesson here i think is just never
apologize to the leftist mob i was
talking about this with megyn kelly
about a month or so ago
we're talking about all these canceled
cancelled people who go out and they
make groveling apologies and they say
please i'm sorry
chris harrison on the bachelor something
like that i'm so sorry and it's pathetic
because it reminds me of that scene in
breaking bad where
where the uh brother-in-law the cop
brother-in-law is lying there you know
the mexican gangster is about to shoot
him
and and hank or rather walter white says
to hank his brother-in-law says
just just grovel please beg apologize
just do whatever and
uh and the brother-in-law on the ground
he said oh you're the smartest guy i
know but you don't realize this guy made
up his mind to kill me 10 minutes ago
the mob is already going to kill you
china made up its mind 10 minutes ago
before
john cena made the apology the question
is not am i going to get to keep my
money am i going to get to keep my
career
the question is am i going to lose my
lose my dignity
while i lose my career that's the only
way you're going to keep your dignity or
are you going to lose your dignity
you know uh china is uh carrying a lot
of sway these days again not just on the
john cena's of the world not just in
hollywood
all the way up to the top joe biden is
getting in trouble because he keeps
quoting chairman mao take a listen
there's a saying we use in a different
context the chinese saying it says
women hold up half the world
it's an absolute stupid position
not to make sure they represent at least
half of what we do
so biden's been quoting this ad nauseum
it's not just an old chinese saying
it's a saying from chairman mao the
communist revolutionary who killed tens
of millions of people in china
maybe the worst mass murderer in world
history
and he's quoting him not why because
because
joe biden's a maoist no there are plenty
of maoists on the left
but because joe biden goes along to get
along and that
is where the left is right now they're
quoting about by the way though speaking
of china
china just they had the one child policy
for a very long time you couldn't have
more more than one kid they would force
abortions and sterilization on you then
it became two children
now it's three children because they
want to avoid a population collapse
and they want to rebuild their family i
think they're seeing a head a little bit
more here
meanwhile here in the united states here
in the west we are doing our damnedest
to destroy the family
through policy through culture through
radical ideologies
that we're going to have to be talking
about now for an entire month we'll have
a lot more to talk about i'm michael
moses the michael knowles she'll see you
tomorrow
if you enjoyed this episode don't forget
to subscribe and if you want to help
spread the word please give us a five
star review
and tell your friends to subscribe we're
available on apple podcasts spotify and
wherever else you listen to podcasts
also be sure to check out the other
daily wire podcasts including the ben
shapiro show
the andrew clavin show and the matte
wall show the michael knowles show is
produced by ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary our
technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show